hey what's going on everybody I would
just want to let all you guys know real
quick that my giveaway is going to be
ending in about two weeks so there's
still plenty of time for you guys to
click the link down in the description
and follow those steps for your chance
to win the complete Game of Thrones
series on blu-ray so after this video
definitely go check that out if you
haven't already and I want to thank all
you guys that has participated in that
giveaway now let's begin the other day I
ran a poll on Twitter asking you guys
what type of video you wanted me to do
next and the majority of you said you
wanted to talk about the bittersweet
ending of this series so let's discuss
that george RR martin has probably been
asked a million times how this story is
going to end and everyone knows he's
never going to reveal how it's actually
going to end until he releases his final
book but he did give us an idea of what
we can expect he said that the ending of
this amazing story will have a
bittersweet ending which does seem
pretty fitting to me considering all the
events that have unfolded during the
process of this story leading up to the
final two books and ever since George
has said that it would be a bittersweet
ending I've been wondering how that's
actually going to play out like what
does he actually mean by that and I
think most of us have a pretty good
sense for the direction this story is
heading in but a bittersweet ending can
mean so many things and after thinking
about this for a while I think there are
a few different ways we can see this
bittersweet ending take place but right
before season 8 begins I will make
another video on this topic in which I
will give my final thoughts on the
ending but for now I want to go over a
few different ways I think this story
can end and personally if I had to bet
money on which way I thought this story
would end I would bet on one of the main
characters dying or maybe even both and
in this video when I say main characters
I'm talking about Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen now of course there are
several other main characters but when
it comes to the end I think Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen
are going to be the key players that are
going to dictate how things are going to
end which is pretty obvious to most
people but I think for the final battle
to lend against the night king we may
have to see one of those characters or
both die in order to win that war and
since Jon Snow is the warrior that will
be on the battlefield who will more than
likely fight the night king one on
one at some point John snow may have to
sacrifice himself in order to save the
Rome which for me would be a very
bittersweet ending in itself John snow
has always been one of my favorite
characters so to see him die and never
come back would certainly be very bitter
but if he died in order to save the rest
of humanity that way life as they know
it could continue and restore itself
then that would be pretty sweet
but since the knight Kings true motives
haven't been revealed he's coming off as
the bad guy in the show he seems to
pretty much murder everyone in his past
in order to complete this mission that
he is on what's right now just appears
to be completely destroying humanity and
there is a chance that during that final
battle when and if John Snow has to
sacrifice himself in order to save
humanity he may even have to become the
new Knight King in order to do so now
that isn't a theory that I believe we
are going to see but it is definitely a
strong possibility which would also be
bittersweet to most people it would be
great to see Jon Snow when the war for
the dawn but to have to sacrifice
yourself and live out the rest of
eternity as the new knight King would
absolutely suck in my opinion another
bittersweet ending would be having all
the Starks die the stark family was the
first family we were introduced to in
the show a family that most people have
not only grown to love but also connect
to one a more personal level so to see
the entire stark family and bloodline be
completely wiped out off the face of
planet coast in the end would be better
as ho this family has already been
through so much so it would be nice to
see some of them actually get to live
out their lives peacefully but to stay
true to the bittersweet ending we could
see this entire family be taken out but
this week part would be that right
before the Starks died they were able to
erase the threat of the others and
having established a system in place
that will allow the remaining survivors
to have a chance to rebuild and
eventually restore life to the way that
it was before all of these wars began
hence the dream of spring something to
look forward to like a bright feature on
the horizon and another bittersweet
ending could be the death of Daenerys
Targaryen and all of the magic that her
dragons have brought Daenerys Targaryen
is definitely a beloved character and
her and her dragon
may even be a fan-favorite over John
snow so to see a character of her status
die would absolutely be a painful and
bitter ending but the final fight can
end with the Dragons dying along with
the knight king and the White Walkers
and any other magic or magical character
we have seen and the world could start
over and go back to the way things were
before with prominent house is running
the Seven Kingdoms again we could even
see a peace pact between the people of
Westeros in the night King we are
definitely going to see a massive amount
of casualties with many of the main
characters dying fan favorites
especially like John and Danny that may
result in the people having to come to a
truce with the ninth king if even
possible which would be a pretty boring
end if you ask me but there are just so
many possibilities but Indiana I think
we will more than likely see the end of
things as we know it the Iron Throne
will no longer be something that people
seek in kill for it may even be
completely destroyed in places like
King's Landing and other major
territories will be completely destroyed
as well in Daenerys and John snow may
both end up dying in the end in order to
beat the night king but there will no
longer be a one world ruler power will
no longer reside in King's Landing
everyone will be able to be independent
and I think Jon Snow will be the key
player in defeating the evil of the
world and if he does die he's going to
make sure that the world is a better
place in the keys to the kingdom are
left in better hands than they were
before and I think Tyrion Lannister will
more than likely play a major role in
restoring Westeros and helping it grow
into a much better society than it has
ever been the end is going to be
bittersweet because of the amount of
casualties we see most of the main
characters we have grown to love are
going to die but ultimately the good
guys will win but life as we know it
will be completely decimated leaving the
final remaining characters the job of
rebuilding a better world we will see
that dream of spring the storm is going
to end the clouds will begin to break
and start to allow the Sun to shine
through and the snow will begin to melt
allowing crops to grow houses will be
rebuilt in society will begin anew
hopefully learning from all of it
mistakes from the past which will give
the future generations a chance to live
in a society that is better than ever
before now these are just a few of the
ways I can see this bittersweet ending
going down and like I said earlier I
will make another video before season 8
begins and which I will give my final
thoughts on the ending but comment below
and give me your thoughts because I'm
really curious to see how others may
think this story is going to end but
before I go I just want to give a quick
shout out the smoke screen and most of
you are probably familiar with his Game
of Thrones YouTube channel by now but
smokescreen was one of the very first
channels that I came across who was
doing Game of Thrones videos and he was
actually the guy that inspired me to
start making videos of my own and never
since I became a part of this community
I have reached out to Chris several
times and he has always been a great guy
and welcomed me with open arms and his
channel was much bigger than mine is
and even when I only had a few
subscribers he would still respond to
all of my comments and questions and for
that I really appreciate it so if you
aren't familiar with this channel please
go and check out his videos and
subscribe to his channels because his
content is really good and I know you
guys will love it too thank you for
taking the time to watch this video I
appreciate each and every one of you
guys and I can't wait to see some of
your ideas on this bittersweet ending so
I will see you guys down in the comment
section have a good day bye